hey this is presh to Walker
this riddle makes the rounds from time
to time and I think it makes for a very
good interview question to see how
people think
a child was playing with a book and tore
out the pages 7 8 100 101 222 and 223.
how many pages did the child tear out
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
the psychologist Daniel Kahneman dealt
two different systems for thinking
system one is fast automatic frequent
emotional and unconscious
system two on the other hand is slow
effortful infrequent calculating and
conscious
so if we use system one thinking to
solve this problem we would see that
there are six numbers which we would
think there are six pages the child tore
out
now that is not the intent of the puzzle
but if we apply system to thinking we
could justify this answer
imagine you have a book where there is
just numbering on one side of the page
or on each leaf
here's an example of such a book there
is just numbering on one side
so it is possible to justify the answer
of six pages because there are some
books that just have numbering on one
side of each sheet
but if you then apply system 2 Thinking
again you'll know this is not the intent
of the puzzle
typically most books will be numbered on
the front and the back of each leaf
so you then might fall into the Trap of
system one thinking that there will only
be three pages that are torn out
seven eight will be on one sheet 100 101
will be on another and 222 and 223 will
be on the third
but again this is the wrong answer
so let's take a look at A Tale of Two
Cities
in this type of book which is a standard
numbering in many books we have odd
numbers on the right hand side and even
numbers on the left hand side
so now let's solve the problem
so 7 will be on the right hand side and
8 will be on the back seven and eight
will be on one sheet
then we have 100 on the left 101 on the
right there will be on two different
sheets
we also have 222 on the left side and
223 on the right side they will be on
different sheets so in total we have
five sheets that are torn out of the
book and that's the intended answer to
the puzzle
but now let's apply system to thinking
one more time
there are books where the odd numbers
are on the left hand side take a look at
the Book of Kells for example where we
have even numbers on the right hand side
and odd numbers on the left hand side
so how would we solve the problem in
this case
we have 7 on the left then we have eight
on the right
we would have 100 on the right side and
on its back side will be 101. we would
also have 222 on the right side and on
the back side will be 223 so this will
be a total of four sheets torn out of
the book
so let's summarize
if we have odd numbers on the right hand
side which is a standard way to number
many books there will be five pages torn
out 7 8 will be on one then we have 100
101 222 and 223.
if we flip it so that odd numbers are on
the left side there will only be four
pages torn out 7 8 then 100 and 101 and
222 and 223.
finally if we just have one number per
Leaf there will be six pages each page
having just one number
so if you've made it this far I want to
thank you for using system two slow
thinking and I just want to point out
one more interesting thing about this
puzzle according to Merriam-Webster the
definition of page is one of the leaves
of a publication or manuscript but it
also means a single side of one of these
leaves
in the first sentence of the riddle
pages is in the context of a page number
so that clearly refers to a numbered
side of a sheet which is the front or
the back
in the second sentence the same word
Pages appears but we intuitively know
this refers to each sheet a front and a
back because the child is tearing a page
out of the book so this is actually a
great credit to system one intuitive and
fast thinking that nobody who reads this
puzzle for the first time would be
confused that the same word Pages means
one thing in the first sentence and
another thing in the second sentence
so this puzzle tests our thinking on
many levels
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]